Let's talk about Chile.
Why is Milton
Friedman tied so tightly with the
Pinochet regime, which was a
repressive, tyrannical
regime that ultimately,
you know, after that period
was over, Chile was for many
years the the kind of best
performing economy in Latin America.
But what did Friedman do?
And is that right to link him
to the Pinochet regime?
Yeah, it's an interesting question
because he didn't spend very much
time in Chile.
So the kind of story starts
with the United States government
funding
students to come and study from
Chile at the University of Chicago,
which was part of a broader kind of
effort to spread American ideas
during the Cold War.
And so this group of students, it's
eventually about a hundred is
trained at Chicago.
Only one of them is actually
Friedman's doctoral student.
But they take classes with him and
they kind of get the whole Chicago
set of economic ideas and then go
back to Chile.
And they really
are a minority, to say the
least, because Chile is following
import substitution
industrialization, ISI, which
creates a very large role for the
state, and it's protectionist
in order to nurture domestic
industries.
And, you know, big companies
and the state are very much
intertwined. And these
they're called the Chicago Boys,
which is pejorative.
And so they want to do, you know,
sort of neoclassical economics,
foreign policy, free markets,
free prices, you know, open trade.
They really get nowhere.
Eventually it's in I think it's in
1973 that
Salvador Allende, who's a socialist
Marxist, is elected.
And then three years later,
I might be getting my exact dates
wrong. I think it's 70 he's
elected. 73 he's overthrown by
Pinochet in a military coup.
It's bloody, it's violent.
And there's a great deal of upheaval
during the Allende regime and
afterwards.
And so when
Pinochet comes into power, the
inflation rate in Chile is 600%
a year.
So it's a sort of macroeconomic
crisis and a political crisis
wrapped in one.
And then a year in,
they've gotten the inflation down
about 300%.
But he's still having a lot of
problems. And it's at that point
that the Chicago boys really
been offstage for most of this,
are able to come and get into
the regime and say, look, we have a
wholly different way to do this.
We have a different set of
approaches. Let's do that.
And as are getting, you know, this
policy considered, they basically
call Friedman and they say, can you
come in? Can you talk about
what we should do to like how we
should manage the economy, how we
can address inflation.
So Friedman decides to come.
He spent six days in the country.
He meets a lot of,
you know, sort of members of the
Chilean state. He meets Pinochet.
He tells him you should
tackle inflation.
You have to do basically a shock
treatment.
You have such bad inflation, you
can't wait. You can't be a
gradualist.
He's is a gradualist in the United
States, but not in this
hyperinflation situation.
So then.
And he also tells Pinochet, if you
open the economy the way you will,
you want to eventually you're going
to have to liberalize.
And from the accounts we have,
Pinochet is basically like, isn't
this going to cause too much social
pain and disruption?
And Friedman says, you kind of have
no choice.
And that's the message he gives to
the country more broadly.
And so I have I found a travelog
where he writes all his like
he the few days after he got back
from Chile, he wrote all this down.
So you have a really good sense of
what his impressions were.
We can't be exactly sure what he
said because it's a censored press.
But most of his talks were like
pretty boring, like,
you know, monetary policy.
At any rate, that is
the policy that's put in place.
And so Friedman really puts his
kind of imprimatur on the
market based reforms.
And he doesn't view this as
advising, you know, a politician
with whom he's aligned.
It's it's not as if he agreed to be
on the Council of Economic Advisors
of Pinochet because he supports
his plan.
You know, he's done it's it's the
context is American economists
flying around the world telling
socialist countries like "become
more capitalist". Right.
It's pretty a common move.
And so then he leaves
and a couple it's not too
long after that one
of Pinochet's leading opponents
who's an exile in the United States,
is assassinated.
By Pinochet?
By Pinochet.
You know, they have this kind of
secret police in a car bomb
on the streets of Washington, D.C.
It's completely shocking.
And then just a couple weeks later,
Friedman gets awarded the Nobel
and the man who was assassinated
was quite critical of Friedman and
interpreted Friedman as a supporter
of Pinochet and even thought
he was part of this kind of
architect of the coup.
So then he's assassinated.
Then the Nobel Prize happened.
So the result is just this.
All gets mixed together and it comes
to seem as if the Nobel Prize
Committee and the sort of
industrialized West has
decided to approve and endorse
the Pinochet regime.
And so that's really a framing
that's put on it
by, you know,
Chilean exiles
and who are very angry with Friedman
and feel like he should just have
steered clear of the country
entirely. So it becomes
just a real it's a real
controversy. It's very painful for
Friedman. And over time, he'll
realize he has to speak
out more forcefully about
political freedom.
You know, his remarks previous to
that are really all about economic
freedom. And eventually he kind of
realizes I have to talk about
political freedom, too.
So you'll see a shift.
One more thing. I would say that you
and I chatted about briefly offline
is that, you know, Friedman doesn't
come out in support of the regime,
but there are some other,
you know, economists, most notably
F.A. Hayek, who offer more
justifications and defenses of
the regime. And I think in the kind
of public memory,
Friedman gets kind of lumped into
that.
And so it's all seen as
this endorsement of a military
government. And Friedman's really
horrified. He's like, I didn't
ever perceive that going there
to give my advice.
You know, the world expert on
inflation, there's 300%
hyperinflation.
Like, of course, I'm going to go and
say, here's what I think should be
done. It doesn't mean I support
Pinochet. So he's
it's a difficult period for him.
Why do you think that
slag against him has
been so long lived, though?
Some of it I just think is
misinformation.
You know, there's there's a belief
that the the coup was done in
the service of this particular set
of economic ideas.
And that's kind of like Naomi
Klein's in her Shock
Doctrine book.
Yeah, there's some dodgy
documentaries where it's seen that
like this was all sort of part of a
master plan and that
it was necessary to, you know,
people were so committed to
capitalism that they needed an
autocratic government to sort of
force it on the country.
So, I mean,
it's it's sort of an inverse
narrative of the connection
between socialism and,
you know, authoritarian regimes.
And so I think it has some power as
being an inversion of that.
So I guess my hope is that with
more information on what happened,
we can have a sort of like a better
understanding of it.
And is that kind of that
connection, is that the origin of
when Friedman really started to talk
about how when you get economic
freedom, political freedom
comes traveling along?
Yeah, I think so.
What happened was then this is
like 75, he goes to Chile,
76 is that Nobel Prize.
And then the Mount Pelerin Society
has its meeting.
I think it's a regional meeting.
And like 1981, which again is
interpreted as like this is an
endorsement.
And Friedman's really worried
about that. And he actually gets
some there is a an economist who
was in the government and he gets
him disinvited to the meeting
because he doesn't want to feel like
there's a connection.
And at this meeting,
Chileans are starting to say
mimic the leftist line that
like we only got capitalism because
we had a strong government and like
we needed that strong government to
get capitalism and freedom.
It's like, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. This is not how it works.
And he starts kind of pushing back
more.
I think he's also trying to push
back against Hayek and then talk
more. And I think, you know, for
most of his career, he's in American
academia and he's taking
political freedom for granted.
And he's thinking, my peers
need to focus more on economic
freedom. And then he gets out into
the world and it's like, oh,
you know, maybe I need to be talking
about political freedom first
because these two are intertwined.